Flattery has a bad name. It’s associated
with saying something upbeat but untrue in
order to hoodwink its unsuspecting target
for low personal gain. In Aesop’s famous
fable, The Fox and the Crow, an ugly crow
has found a piece of cheese and retired to
a branch to eat it. A sly fox, wanting it
for himself, flatters the crow, calling it
beautiful and wondering whether its voice
will be as sweet as its appearance. The crow
lets out a horrific screeching sound and the
cheese drops straight into the fox’s gaping
expectant mocking jaw. But there’s another
form of flattery with more valuable and ethical
ambitions. Parents of small children invariably
discover its uses – which deserve to be
better known and practiced around all age
groups. Let’s imagine that a child isn’t
yet entirely kind to their brother, or good
at drawing, or a perfect cook or helpful around
the house – but the parent declares that
they are so as to encourage and make more
concrete what is as yet only tentative and
fragile in their ambivalent nature. The child
is being helped to end up as some of the things
he has already been described as being. In
1956, the Brazilian architect Oscar Niemeyer
was invited to create a new capital city for
his nation: Brasilia. Brazil is a country
of frenetic economic activity, of rainforest
and Amazonian villages, favelas, soccer, beaches
and intense disagreement about political priorities…
none of which is apparent from contemplation
of the beautiful, serene, futuristic rational
architecture of Brasilia. One day, the buildings
propose, Brazil will be a place where rationality
is powerful; where order and harmony reign;
where elegance is normal. There will be no
more corruption or chaos. In offices, efficient
secretaries will type up judicious briefing
notes; the filing systems will be perfect
– nothing will get lost, overlooked, neglected
or mislaid; negotiations will take place in
an atmosphere of impersonal wisdom. The country
will be perfectly managed. Oscar Niemeyer’s
capital is an essay in flattery. It hints
that certain desirable qualities which are
as yet only very latent could one day be central
to the country and its governing class. Shortly
after the capital buildings were completed,
a journalist asked Niemeyer why he had designed
a capital that was so dramatically unlike
the country it was meant to represent. ‘It
won’t be one day,’ said Niemeyer – with
a wry smile. Brazilians continue to wait.
And the finest buildings of Brasilia continue
to inspire. We need flattery because we so
badly need to be guided to develop beyond
what we are right now. We need other people’s
belief in us to bolster our capacities for
reform and growth. We need a chance to grow
into the person we have flatteringly been
described as already being. Consider a painting
by Velázquez, The Surrender of Breda. There’s
been a battle between Spain and the Netherlands.
Spain has won. The picture shows the Spanish
general, Spinola receiving the key to the
city of Breda from the representative of the
defeated Dutch forces, Justin of Nassau. What’s
striking is how cordial everything is. Historians
report that both sides behaved extremely well.
There was no recrimination or wanton bloodshed.
The painting is a memorial to unusually noble
conduct. But it’s not a comprehensive or
accurate account of war or sieges; just as
Brasilia is not a completely accurate presentation
of what Brazil is like. Instead, each of these
works presents an ideal in the hope of generating
a subsequent reality. We should learn to be
gentler on flattery and the energy it can
lend us to move towards greater generosity,
intelligence and wisdom. We should use its
benign power in order to bring about a world
where we’ll more often be able simply to
praise one another, and no longer merely just to flatter.
We believe in making the world a more emotionally intelligent place
and to that end we have now also published some extraordinary books.
As well as other merchandise that reinforces some of the other themes illustrated in our videos.
Please click on the link below to see more.